[Musique]
avec nous Bruno gugliel Minetti
consultant en communication numérique et
animateur du balado d'actualité
numérique mon carnet bonsoir alors
beaucoup de nouvelles au cours des
derniers jours entourants monsieur Mosk
et Twitter on va faire le tour de tout
ça mais d'abord commencer par ce fameux
sondage est-ce que vous croyez qu'il va
bel et bien quitter la taille de Twitter
bah écoutez effectivement comme il en
avait pris possession à la fin octobre
le 16 novembre il avait donné une
entrevue à l'intérieur de se retrouver
là il avait confirmé que il n'allais pas
rester longtemps à la tête de Twitter
l'idée là-dedans il y a d'autres
occupations notamment Tesla et SpaceX
qui prennent un peu de son temps et donc
là effectivement il était à la recherche
d'un
PDG et j'ai bien dit qu'en fin de
semaine j'ai vu ce fameux sondage là
parce que évidemment il a utilisé pour
faire une opération de communication ça
a bien fonctionné ça a bien fonctionné
parce que là on en parle encore de lui
aujourd'hui mais c'est ça alors il est à
la recherche de quelqu'un et ça sera pas
facile parce que le candidat devra de
voir va devoir travailler avec la
pression de diriger ce réseau-là c'est
pas rien mais aussi la pression d'avoir
un patron ou un propriétaire qui est
très présent dans la gestion de ces
entreprises à quel point justement
risque-t-il de rester quand même très
actif dans les décisions même si le kit
le poste de PDG si on parle pourcentage
c'est probablement de l'ordre de 125 à
130% très très tentant pour un nouveau
PDG ça non effectivement alors ça sera
probablement quelqu'un en qui il est
très confiant c'est qu'il y a déjà
travaillé avec lui ou sinon il va
vraiment nous surprendre avec un
candidat qui est qui avec qui il a un
certain lien là et qui a déjà travaillé
avec lui mais l'idée là dedans c'est ça
c'est qu'il peut pas prendre quelqu'un
qui est réputé pour diriger de maintenir
parce que la main de faire dans cette
opération-là c'est lui et il veut pas
nécessairement se retrouver en
confrontation avec le dirigeant ou la
dirigeante et aujourd'hui on apprenait
le département américain du commerce va
scruter plus attentivement
l'acquisition de Twitter qu'est-ce qui
en est exactement ce qui arrive c'est
qu'en mai dernier Twitter a été trouvé
coupable d'utiliser les numéros de
téléphone de ces abonnés à ma mauvaise
édition essentiellement les numéros de
téléphone intelligés pour envoyer de la
publicité directement aux utilisateurs
de Twitter ce qui n'était pas permis
tout à fait qui vient en
opposition là avec les lois américaines
et donc ils ont été trouvés coupables
ils ont une amende de 150 millions de
dollars ma mémoire est bonne et donc et
le FTC avait dit qu'ils allaient les
garder à l'oeil mais là avec tous les
changements récents qui sont passés chez
Twitter notamment il y a le départ de
5000 employés sur 7500 et là dedans que
tous ceux qui étaient en charge la
sécurité des utilisateurs de Twitter et
ça c'est autant au niveau des respects
des règles gouvernementales que autant
de la sécurité du réseau bah le FTC se
pose des questions sur la sécurité du
réseau lui-même mais aussi l'utilisation
des données de ces utilisateurs alors de
là le message qui a été envoyé
aujourd'hui et ça c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour Elon Musk et son équipe
parce que qu'est-ce qu'elle pourrait
faire concrètement concrètement si il
trouve que il convient pourraient avoir
une amende salée qui pourrait facilement
monter à des centaines de millions et
peut-être même atteindre la somme de 1
milliard s'il y a vraiment beaucoup de
gens qui sont concernés par une mauvaise
utilisation de leur donner personnelle
dans le cadre de l'opération de Twitter
une des contreverses que beaucoup retenu
la tension ce sont ces comptes de
journalistes qui ont été suspendus puis
rétabli comment avez-vous lu cette
situation qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
exactement mais le premier je dois cette
histoire là faut savoir que
dans notre boule lapsus mais Elon Musk a
pas nécessairement les journalistes dans
son cœur en partant d'ailleurs si vous
regardez
enfin il s'est excusé il a dit qu'à
partir de maintenant mais il revenait à
sa pratique ancienne c'est-à-dire de
faire des sondages sur son réseau
Twitter et de là ce que vous annonciez
que maintenant les gens qui seront
consultés pour les nouvelles directives
sur Twitter ce sont les gens qui
payeront pour l'abonnement payant de
Twitter mais donc c'est ça alors il
avait avancé le fait que on ne pourrait
plus utiliser Twitter pour faire de la
publier de la publicité pour du contenu
que je trouvais sur certaines
plateformes notamment Facebook Instagram
des plateformes qui sont très utilisés
dans le monde alors évidemment ben ça
contrevenait avec l'intérêt de la
plupart des utilisateurs et d'ailleurs
il y a eu un sondage qui s'est fait sur
le compte Twitter safety et non pas sur
son compte donc beaucoup moins de gens
ont voté et on est arrivé avec une
confirmation que les gens ne voulaient
pas de ce type de réglementation alors
ça aura pas lieu on est revenu à la
politique ancienne volte-face encore une
fois merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI